ha llegado la hora de resolver
desigualdades pero desigualdades con
valor absoluto y muchos comentarios de
que las desigualdades como el de
absoluto es que es la parte más difícil
de toda la dga ahora sin embargo usando
todo lo que hemos aprendido hasta
ahorita de ecuaciones con valor absoluto
vas a ver que no es tan difícil como se
piensa lo único que necesitamos es
recordar todo lo que hemos visto así que
déjenme empezar con una desigualdad
bastante sencilla el valor absoluto de x
es menor que 12 y recuerda que una de
las formas en las que veíamos el valor
absoluto era como la distancia la
distancia que teníamos de un cierto
número al 0 es decir que otra forma de
ver esta desigualdad es pensar en los
números cuya distancia al cero sea menor
que 12 así que déjame hacer que una
recta numérica y aquí voy a poner el 0 y
lo que estoy buscando son los números
que estén a una distancia menor de dos
unidades del cero y si te das cuenta son
todos estos yo pongo aquí el 12 de aquí
el menos 12 todos los números cuya
distancia al cero es menor que 12 pues
son todos estos que estoy tomando aquí
todos todos estos porque por ejemplo si
tomo el 1
el un día una distancia al 0 menor que
12 unidades si por ejemplo me tomo el 11
entonces está una distancia del 0 menor
que 12 unidades y así conseguir con
todos estos números de aquí es decir que
otra forma de ver esto son todas las
equis que son mayores que menos 12 date
cuenta que son las x que son más grandes
que menos 12 pero no todas tenemos que
pagarle hasta que llegamos al 12 es
decir vamos a tomarnos todas las x que
son mayores que el menos 12 y además
todas las x que son menores que 12 que
se cumplan estas dos igualdades
simultáneamente que seamos mayores que
menos 12 y menores que 12 como por
ejemplo el menos 3 el menos 3 es más
grande que menos 12 pero es menor que 12
y por lo tanto la distancia que hay del
menos 3 al 0 es menor que 12 y así
podemos pensar en todos estos números
que por cierto si esto mismo lo vemos
una noción de intervalos yo podría decir
que el intervalo solución de esta
desigualdad es de menos 12 a 12 en
paréntesis porque recuerda que no
tocamos al 12 ni al menos 12 porque
tanto el 12,12 están a una distancia
igual a 12 unidades
del 0 imposible también lo podemos poner
de esta forma menos 12 es menor que x
menor que 12 estas son las tres formas
de escribir la solución de esta
desigualdad y fíjate que es bastante
sencillo si nosotros pensamos en la
distancia que tenemos al cero así que
vamos a ver otro ejemplo el valor
absoluto de 7x es mayor o igual a 21 es
decir estamos fijando en los números
tales que la distancia que hay al cero
multiplicada por 7 sea mayor o igual a
21 o lo podemos ver así lo que está
adentro del valor absoluto es decir 7x
si nos fijamos en lo que está dentro del
valor absoluto y nos tomamos la
distancia al cero tiene que ser mayor o
igual a 21 por lo tanto la idea y la
noción es la misma así que déjame hacer
una recta numérica voy a poner aquí el
cero aquí el 21 y aquí el menos 21 y me
estoy preguntando por algo que la
distancia al cero sea mayor que 21 es
decir lo que está dentro del valor
absoluto quiero que tenga una distancia
mayor
1 al 0 por lo tanto lo que estoy
diciendo es que me voy a fijar en todos
los números que están aquí es decir
todos los números menores que menos 21
todos los números menores que menos 21 y
de hecho vamos a tocar el menos 21 pues
es mayor o igual es decir también
estamos aceptando las distancias que
estén a 21 unidades del 0 y fíjate
cualquier número que tenemos aquí
cualquier número que sea menor que menos
21 por ejemplo en menos 30 está una
distancia mayor que 21 unidades del 0 y
también todos estos de aquí del 21 en
adelante incluyendo el 21 porque mi
desigualdad es mayor o igual por ejemplo
si tomamos el 40 el 40 está una
distancia mayor o igual a 21 unidades
del cero y bueno ya que tenemos estos
dos posibles intervalos entonces fíjate
si me tomo cualquier número aquí en esto
que estoy extrayendo de verde esto
quiere decir que 7x tiene que ser menor
o igual que menos 21 es decir no estoy
fijando en todos los números que sean
menores o iguales a menos 21 o en su
dado caso 7x tiene que ser mayor o igual
a 21 lo que está dentro de él
ahora absoluto tiene que ser mayor o
igual que 21 pues todos los números que
son mayores o iguales que 21 tiene una
distancia más grande o igual al 0 que 21
unidades y perfecto ya que tenemos estas
dos desigualdades 7 x menor o igual a
menos 21 o en su dado caso 7 x mayor o
igual a menos 21 podemos de cada una de
ellas despejar a x utilizando las
propiedades de las desigualdades y
recuerdan aquí lo más importante es ver
que lo que está dentro del valor
absoluto lo que sea que esté adentro
cumplan mi desigualdad es decir
fijémonos en las distancias y bueno si
divido ambos lados entre 7 que me va a
quedar pues 7 x entre 7 me da x mientras
que la desigualdad se conserva y me
queda x menor o igual a menos 21 37 que
es menos 3 o en su dado caso en la otra
desigualdad me queda que x es mayor o
igual a 3 es decir 21 entre 7 pues la
desigualdad se conserva y ya está
tengo ya el conjunto solución de todas
las x que cumplen esta desigualdad con
valor absoluto todas las x que son
o igual a menos 3 o en su dado caso
todas las x que son mayores o iguales a
3 es más dejemos poner una recta
numérica para que veamos las soluciones
y ojo la recta numérica que puse aquí
arriba fue la que nos ayudó a entender
el problema de mi desigualdad con valor
absoluto sin embargo esta recta numérica
que estoy poniendo de rojo este de aquí
es un intervalo solución de este
problema de esta desigualdad todas las x
que son mayores o iguales que 3 todas
estas que estoy poniendo aquí y también
todas las x que son menores o iguales a
menos 3 y ya está ya tenemos la solución
de otra desigualdad competerán absoluto
ya te cuenta que si nosotros pensamos en
distancias no es tan difícil así que
bueno vamos a hacer otro par de ejemplos
para que vayamos agravando más práctica
y te des cuenta que no son tan difíciles
ni imposibles de resolver así que
tomemos otro ejemplo me voy a tomar el
valor absoluto de quien se me ocurre
tomar el valor absoluto de 5x
a 35 x 3 y esto lo voy a ser menor que 7
y entonces ya va a ser mucho más rápido
mucho más fácil porque estamos buscando
algo es decir lo que está dentro del
valor absoluto quiero que cumpla que su
distancia al cero sea menor que 7 y
entonces si hacemos una recta numérica
de que me estoy refiriendo aquí tengo al
cero y por acá tengo el 7 y por acá
tengo al menos 7 también se va a cumplir
que necesito todos los números que estén
en este intervalo porque todos los
números que están en ese intervalo su
distancia el 0 es menor que 7 y por lo
tanto me queda que 5 x 3 esto tiene que
ser en primer lugar mayor que menos 7
estoy buscando todas las x que cumplan
que 5x más 3 sea mayor que menos 7 y a
su vez al mismo tiempo se tiene que
cumplir que 5x más 3 sea menor que 7 es
decir para que estemos en este intervalo
solución estamos buscando las x que
cumplan simultáneamente estas dos
desigualdades y por lo tanto si ya está
en vuestras desigualdades entonces no
puedo poner resolverlas por ejemplo aquí
yo tengo 5 x es mayor que menos 7 menos
tres es decir
pase el 3 del otro lado con signo
contrario y después y divido ambos lados
entre 5 me queda que x es mayor que
menos 2 aquí me queda que 5x debe ser
menor que 7 menos tres los cuales 4 es y
dividido todo entre 5 me queda que x
tiene que ser menor que cuatro quintos o
dicho otra manera como se tiene que
cumplir ambas desigualdades al mismo
tiempo mi conjunto solución va a ser del
-2 al cuatro quintos abierto pues mi
desigualdad no era menor o igual era
menor estricto y bueno ya que tenemos
esto entonces quiero que lo visualizas
de la siguiente manera x está en el
intervalo entre menos dos y cuatro
quintos es decir que menos dos es menor
que x menos cuatro quintos o yo podemos
ver también en su forma gráfica sin
embargo ya ver de su forma gráfica es
muy sencillo ya sabes cómo lo podemos
ver estamos buscando las x que estén
entre menos dos y cuatro quintos porque
al final lo que estamos haciendo es que
se cumplan
ambas desigualdades al mismo tiempo y
quiero que te des cuenta que ya podemos
como visualizar una regla para estas
desigualdades si me tomo el valor
absoluto de fx esto menor que am
entonces te cuenta que caemos en este
mismo ejemplo y este mismo ejemplo
termina
diciendo que esto que tenemos aquí es
exactamente lo mismo que tomarnos a fx
en el intervalo entre menos a y ya a
todas las equis que cumplan que la
distancia de fx sea menor que a y por lo
tanto estamos atrapados entre dos
valores entre el valor de menos a y el
valor de amd menos a menor que fx menor
que han dicho de otra manera fx es mayor
que menos a y a su vez simultáneamente
fx es menor que a esto es justo como lo
estábamos viendo esto en el caso de que
tengamos el valor absoluto de algo menor
que a si tenemos al revés el valor
absoluto de algo es mayor que a lo que
estoy buscando son distancias que estén
mucho más lejos que am estamos buscando
las x que cumplan que la distancia de fx
al cero sea mucho más grande que hay y
si recuerdas el ejemplo pasado solamente
pasa cuando fx es más grande que a esto
tiene toda la lógica del mundo o en su
dado caso
fx es menor que menos a porque cualquier
valor que te tomes menor que menos a
cualquier valor que dentro no es menor
que menos a va a estar a una distancia
más lejos que menos
0 y fíjate que quiere una gran
diferencia en el primer caso en el caso
de verde estamos pidiendo que las
desigualdades se cumplan
simultáneamente al mismo tiempo f x
mayor que menos a y f x menor que a
mientras que en el caso de amarillo en
nuestro segundo caso lo que buscamos es
que pase una o la otra o que fx sea más
grande que hay en su dado caso que fx
sea menor que menos a así que con esta
regla que no sería muy bueno que te
aprendida de memoria vamos a intentar
hacer un siguiente ejercicio recuerda
que es mucho más importante que tú
entiendas la base del concepto y a mí me
gusta mucho pensarlo pues el concepto de
distancia así que me voy a tomar el
siguiente ejercicio el valor absoluto de
dos céntimos de x esto más nueve quiero
que sea mayor que cinco séptimos 2x
entre 79 en valor absoluto quiero que
sea mayor que cinco séptimos y bueno
vamos a usar esta regla que estamos
utilizando quiero que 2x entre 79 el
valor absoluto de esto sea mayor que
cinco séptimos entonces tenemos dos
casos o que 2x entre 7 más 9 sea más
grande que cinco séptimos
este sería nuestro primer caso o en su
dado caso y ojo es o en su dado caso 2 x
entre 7 y 9 esto sea menor que menos
cinco séptimos porque fíjate si nosotros
tomamos cualquier cosa que sea menor que
menos cinco séptimos y tomamos su valor
absoluto su valor absoluto va a ser más
grande que decimos séptimos así que ya
está ya tengo aquí mis dos desigualdades
que tenemos que resolver y bueno como ya
tengo dos desigualdades que resolver qué
te parece si para quitarnos problemas
multiplicamos todo primero por 7 me
queda 2x más 63 esto es mayor que 5 y 2
x más 63 esto es menor que menos 59 por
7 63 y bueno ahora vamos a despejar la x
y para esto voy a pasar este 63 del otro
lado restando y me queda que 2x va a ser
más grande que 5 63 lo cual es 58 58
mientras que de este lado me queda que
2x es menor que menos 563 lo cual es
menos 68 68 2x es menor que menos 68 y
2x es
porque -58 aquí me faltan menos perdón y
ahora voy a dividir ambos lados de cada
una de estas cualidades entre dos para
que ya me quede el valor de x despejado
en la primera desigualdad me queda que x
es mayor que menos 58 entre 2 lo cual me
da menos 29 menos 29 ya tengo aquí mi
primer intervalo solución o en su dado
caso también podría ser que x sea menor
que menos 68 entre 2 que es menos 34
menos 34 perfecto ya tengo mis dos
intervalos opciones y como se van a ver
estos intervalos en mi recta numérica
así que déjame dibujar una recta
numérica y vamos a ver qué nos está
diciendo esta información aquí tengo el
menos 29 por acá tengo en menos 34 y yo
lo que quiero son las x que cumplan que
van a ser mayores que menos 29 y ojo el
intervalo sea abierto porque no toca el
29 todas estas de aquí todas estas aquí
esto es por una parte o en todo caso
también cumplen aquellas x que son
menores que menos 34 abierto entonces
todas estas de aquí
cualquier x que te tomes en este
intervalo va a cumplir con esta
desigualdad